[Applauso]
oggi vi racconterò tre storie
siamo a roma è il 2022 e semestre
universitario è appena iniziato
agli studenti poco più che ventenni
viene chiesto di presentarsi al resto
dei compagni come con la propria
biografia al social si si avete capito
bene proprio quella descrizione piccola
e sintetica che abbiamo tutti accanto la
nostra foto di instagram è che
tendenzialmente urla tutto di noi al
mondo o almeno così credeva il
professore uno ad uno gli studenti
sfilano esibiscono la propria
c'è chi ha solo una foto c'è chi ha solo
il proprio nome e chi invece ha scelto
una sola frase per dire tutto di sé
professore un po sotto choc chiede ai
propri studenti come mai non avessero
una biografia più corposa insomma una
vera biografia
i miei amici sanno già chi sono risponde
il primo
social non sono una cosa seria
quindi non mi sono preso troppo sul
serio dice secondo
i contenuti che posto sono sufficienti
dicono già abbastanza di me dice il
terzo la frase che ho scelto
rappresenta perfettamente chi sono dice
l'ultimo guardando il professore anche
con una leggera rassegnazione quel chi
sono arriva nella mente del professore
come una doccia fredda e ancora fa
fatica a capire l'approssimazione e che
gli appena stata servita
ora vi porto con me nel deserto del
coral eco è il 2021 siamo offerte
ventura e stiamo a sorvolando il deserto
questa questo deserto bacia
letteralmente l'oceano è uno spettacolo
sono le ore 20 il sole ancora alto ma
sta per tramontare sarà tramontato di lì
a 5 minuti
ovviamente non siamo gli unici arrivati
fin qui per godere di questa meraviglia
tra le dune possiamo scorgere un gruppo
di ragazze una coppia è un gruppo di
ragazzi sul lato una più estrema
le ragazze sono intenti a rotolarsi
dentro la duna esibendo delle pose
plastiche bellissime ovviamente sono
alla ricerca del boomerang perfetto la
coppia che credevamo essere un romantico
duo in realtà si sta passando
vicendevolmente il telefono in una
staffetta infinita di best picture of
trade
i ragazzi sulla duna più estrema e loro
si stanno letteralmente ammucchiando
braccio alzato stanno facendo in sel
fida bomber sono le ore 20 e 10 adesso
il sole tramontata nessuno di loro ha
veramente visto il tramonto
giro di boa
ora siamo a new york e
1979 e anti world sta spopolando sulla
scena mondana della city infatti sta
commentando con un suo carissimo amico
giornalista l'ultima serata mondana
passata insieme
è pazzesco e sempre nel posto sbagliato
il momento giusto è per questo che amo
la fotografia di ron galella
dicendo
beh non è il più amato dei paparazzi
d'america in quel momento e fotografa le
celebrities nei momenti più inopportuni
che gli piaccia o meno da marlon brando
a brad pitt da courtney love a britney
spears
la regola per ron è sempre la stessa
una buona fotografia deve essere a fuoco
e deve fotografare qualcuno di molto
famoso mentre fa qualcosa di
assolutamente non famoso
mi fa sorridere questo consiglio di rom
perché oggi noi millennio in realtà
postiamo sui social proprio per essere
un po più famosi
invece ciò che è interessante che le
nuove generazioni
catturano attimi rubati solo per
esprimersi
non fraintendetemi abbiamo un sacco di
cose in comune tantissimo
siamo entrambi i figli della rivoluzione
digitale e stiamo assistendo a degli
eventi storici inediti la pandemia la
crisi climatica
la globalizzazione spinta le guerre
moderne in casa e ancora entrambi
entrambe queste generazioni sono stati
incompresi e sezionati da marchettari
sociologi educatori brand nel disperato
tentativo di capire che cosa avessero
nella testa
questi nuovi figli di internet
nonostante questo quindi nonostante
tutte questi tratti in comune
noi millenial chiamati dagli americani
la generazione del look at me guardami
siamo proprio quelli che al tramonto
sono disposti a rotolarsi per cinque
minuti di fila pur di ottenere lo scatto
perfetto quello memorabile
la vostra generazione invece
probabilmente benché definita sempre
connessa su quelle dune avrebbe visto il
tramonto
proprio perché siete sempre connessi
voi sapete quando this connettervi siete
estremamente selettivi la vostra
comunicazione è sincera e schietta
abbiamo visto no non hanno una biografia
non hanno intenzionalmente una biografia
non seguono i brand
seguono intenzionalmente i brand che gli
interessano
non portano ciò che è bello voi postate
ciò che vi piace e quando andate ad un
concerto non lo filmate costantemente lo
stremate live nei millenni bene in
millenni ha certo che abbiamo una
biografia
non dice niente di noi ma dice tutto ciò
che facciamo o che vorremmo fare
seguiamo i brand ne seguiamo moltissimi
perché crediamo di avere una relazione
con loro d'altronde siamo cresciuti a
pane tv e pubblicità negli anni quanta e
quando andiamo ad un concerto scattiamo
moltissime foto
perché
vogliamo selezionare solo le migliori
per portarle subito dopo l'evento
e ancora non possiamo ciò che ci piace
non ho postiamo ciò che è bello
possibilmente in un certo modo e anche
in un certo momento
insomma mentre noi siamo così impegnati
ad essere i curatori della nostra
immagine
voi siete intenti a far i curatori della
vostra vita
ora per un momento vorrei la complicità
della sala di chi non è della
generazione z per provare a ricordarci
che cosa abbiamo fatto durante il lock
dow
abbiamo utilizzato qualsiasi tecnologia
di videoconferenza per fare il nostro
lavoro in realtà nello stesso modo in
cui facevamo prima quello che era un
meeting fisico è diventato semplicemente
una videoconferenza tantissima e
videoconferenze aggiungerei
abbiamo sperimentato testato la data una
didattica distanza per in realtà a
insegnare in un modo non poi così
differente da quello che facciamo in
classe semplicemente c'era uno schermo
di mezzo
insomma abbiamo fatto riferimento ai
canali che c'erano già cari e abbiamo
semplicemente aumentato le ore di
utilizzo e mentre noi ci coccolava mo
nelle nostre norme sociali ben definite
e aumentavamo il ventaglio di canali
inutilizzo i giovani i più giovani le
hanno ridotte queste tecnologie hanno
scelto pochi precisi canali con cui
continua a esprimersi con cui restare in
contatto sviluppare il loro linguaggio e
anche iniziare una silenziosa
rivoluzione
pensateci cabile ci ha insegnato che
passano 5 secondi per far ridere e che
un canale solo quello giusto è del tutto
sufficiente per aver successo
quello che è noto in lockdown dalla noia
oggi è diventato il suo
un linguaggio comico
filiali
a 17 anni ci ha dimostrato che si può
essere direttore creativo di se stessi e
scegliere per esempio di vestirsi con
gli abiti vecchi quindi estremamente
larghi privi di qualsiasi
sessualizzazione nel mondo patinato del
pop
e c'è anche insegnato che si può cantare
di amore ma si può anche cantare di
ansia di morte
e mentre noi tutti eravamo chiusi in
casa
la musica dei money skin arrivava in
america in europa
ha colmato un vuoto e ha riscritto il
linguaggio del rock con i suoi temi
quelli della sua generazione dalla
fluidità
all'uguaglianza al rispetto per ognuno
andando oltre l'ossessione del cash e
del brand che caratterizzavano la trap e
rep
insomma noi temiamo di spezzare i
modelli voi li sfidate noi temiamo
tantissimo che le tecnologie ci
sostituiscano voi le abbracciate per
creare dei nuovi lavori
navy giudichiamo voi ve ne infischiate
giusto
l'imperfezione è il vostro super potere
e arriva a dritto al nostro cuore senza
filtri
e ron galella l'aveva capito nel 79
d'altronde nel
nell'imperfezione di uno scatto rubato
di una posa non esibita dei un
imprevisto si nasconde la forza
comunicativa più dirompente la stessa
che quegli studenti hanno servito ai
propri compagni e al proprio professore
quel giorno in quella classe a roma quel
professore millenial
completamente spaesato ero io
non avevo capito avevo giudicato la
quasi assenza della loro biografia
una scelta ben precisa per
approssimazione per pigrizia quasi
non avevo non avevo capito che nella
sintesi che quegli studenti mi stavano
proponendo si nascondeva la mia prossima
lezione
attenzione non quella che avrei fatto
quella che avrei imparato
quella che di solito non ti aspetti
abbiamo la grandissima opportunità oggi
di fermarci un ottimo smettere di
giudicare e reimparare a utilizzare i
nostri canali di comunicazione per
tornare a essere un po più curatori
della nostra vita perché la verità è che
saremo davvero qualcuno solo se sapremo
restare diversi dagli altri
loro voi ragazzi che siete seduti oggi
in questa zona lo avete capito e potete
insegnarci e quindi siete disposti a
insegnarci no
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]